[Musique]
notre adn c'est bien sûr de de
rassembler tous les historiens
d'importance mais aussi des passeurs des
vulgarisateurs valade et des
journalistes qui se sont passionnés eux
pour un sujet et qui ont envie de le
transmettre puis les comédiens
[Musique]
cette année c'est un record historique
j'allais dire nous aurons 191 auteurs
présents
un peuple privé d'histoire quelque part
et et privés d'avenir et on doit
continuer à cultiver cette culture
historique toute sa vie
[Musique]
cette année on aura un grand débat
vraiment dédié que pour les jeunes bull
seront enracinée dans notre histoire
plus plus ils seront forts et bien dans
leur peau demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes à 57 vidéaste qui ont
présenté leurs vidéos ou au jury et donc
il ya un prix du public tout le monde
peut sur le site histoire de dire point
fr votez regarder ses vidéos et choisir
son son meilleur vidéaste et le vendredi
19 novembre à l'ugc
ce lieu donc la cérémonie de remise de
prix